c'est que entrant l'espace de débat
public l'espace pour la réalisation des
droits civiques et politiques est en
train d'être réduit
comment pourquoi est ce que je dis ça
pourquoi est-ce qu amnesty international
dit ça tout d'abord parce que là le
droit de manifester a fait l'objet de
nombreuses restrictions au cours des
dernières années et en particulier au
cours de la dernière année
parce que les l'utilisation d'armes non
non létale par la police a créé à et la
cause des deux blessures
incroyable la loi de sécurité globale à
renforcer le pouvoir des forces de
l'ordre à imposer une forme de
surveillance a contraint les les témoins
les citoyens à être beaucoup plus sur
leurs gardes
quand ils ont quand ils sont les témoins
de violences policières il s'agit bien
là d'un carton rouge il s'agit bien là
de dire attention les derniers
développements depuis depuis quelques
années en particulier en 2020 vont dans
une direction qui est extrêmement
nocives problématique et possiblement
même dangereuse pour l'ensemble des des
droits et libertés en france
la france a pris des mesures sur la
banque dame qui sont qui sont là aussi
difficile à mettre en a à comprendre
la france est l'un des plus grands
exportateurs d'armes au niveau
international y compris par exemple en
arabie saoudite
nous vendons des armes à des états qui
sont reconnus comme responsables de
crimes de guerre de crimes contre
l'humanité etc
en ce qui concerne les enfants
djihadistes sujet extrêmement douloureux
et est sensible la position d'amnesty
international est très claire
la france a une responsabilité aux yeux
du droit international elle a une
responsabilité de protéger
elle a une responsabilité de protéger
qui est mise en oeuvre et qui doit être
mise en oeuvre
extraterritoriale mans il y a à
l'extérieur de la frontière française
des français en particulier qui dont la
vie est menacée des français qui
pourraient être torturés ou qui sont
torturés des français qui sont démunis
face à des attaques
il en revient à la france d'utiliser
toutes les ressources dont elles
bénéficient pour aller sauver ces gens
là
la déclaration de 1789 n'est pas un gage
du tout il faut la mettre en oeuvre
chaque jour chaque heure il faut faire
acte de solidarité à l'égard de tout le
monde
il faut mettre en oeuvre les les valeurs
de respect les valeurs contre le racisme
contre le sexisme
il faut respecter la diversité des
opinions politiques delà de l'espace
civique le droit de manifester est
absolument primordial quand on s'engage
dans une politique qui remet en cause
ses droits nous nous engageons dans une
politique la france s'engage dans une
politique extrêmement nocive pour
l'ensemble des droits humains
[Musique]
où